[Music]
tonight on a special edition of Brian
Ross investigates investigative
journalists making a difference the
reporters who track down this
surveillance tape revealing what
happened in the back rooms of an Indiana
police station something the police
chief described as a minor incident and
then jumped on top of them to punch
Timothy the reporter in Alaska who
discovered police in the state's remote
villages who themselves had criminal
records one accused of raping this
teenage girl plus the reporter who went
undercover in a notorious for-profit
prison to expose the chaos the public
wasn't supposed to see in Philadelphia
the reporters with their own undercover
project using teachers to test and
expose dangerous conditions in the city
schools it was like a drug deal or
something and taking on President Trump
on behalf of the New York Times the New
York Times is totally dishonest he
doesn't get a byline but what he wrote
in this letter made big news from the
long crime Network studios in New York
City's Herald Square this is a special
edition of Brian Ross investigates good
evening and welcome tonight we look at
some of the great local investigative
reporting that we've been highlighting
this year beginning with reporters in
Indiana who took on what is always a
tough assignment police betraying their
commitment to honesty and integrity it
was only after this video was finally
made public that it became known what
really happened to the suspect being
dragged out of this police car and
police officials and officers in Elkhart
Indiana held to account the man's name
was Mario go era and ledesma under
arrest for domestic battery so he was
brought into a detention area at the
police department he was placed on a
chair and with his uh hence cuffed
behind his back reporter Christian
suckler of the South Bend review had
already been working on how the Elkhart
Indiana police to
but handled allegations of misconduct
when he came across this case at one
point he turned and began to spit
towards one officer that officer and
another and then jumped on top of them
and punched him in the face repeatedly
but the police at first put out a much
different version police chief and
wooden Bigler downplayed it to the
police oversight Commission and I think
they just went a little overboard when
they when they took him to the ground
without the video
the Chiefs version a little overboard
became the official version he made no
mention of them throwing any punches and
really he just consistently downplayed
what had really happened in the police
stations detention area ken Armstrong is
a reporter with a non-profit group
ProPublica which has created a fund to
help support local investigative
journalism getting the video in Indiana
made all the difference
he's left on the ground bleeding
afterwards for about six minutes then
he's taken out on a stretcher you know
so this was not something where two
officers simply went a little overboard
it went well beyond that when the South
Bend Tribune published the video it also
identified the two other officers in the
room and the two other officers included
the mayor's son I'm Sergeant through
nice he was the only supervisor in the
room and the other officer in the room
at the time the beating of curve was the
head of the local Fraternal Order of
Police and neither of those two officers
stopped the beating as it occurred but
they walked over as it ends and one of
them says stop and if Christian and with
your help had not pushed for the video
what do you think would have happened I
don't think anything would have happened
you know when the police chief
reprimanded the two officers in June of
2018 he concluded his letter reprimand
with the line I now consider this matter
closed with an exclamation point
but the Tribune reporting made it
impossible to close the case top police
officials
blame the newspaper for all its problems
Oh carts Assistant Police Chief Todd
Thayer made an impassioned speech about
his anger over the reports in the
tribunal everything is going why are
they coming over here into our backyard
and trying to disrupt everything that we
built since then the chief was forced to
resign the mayor has announced he will
not run for re-election and the two
officers who actually threw the punches
seen in the video they have been charged
with misdemeanor battery and are
awaiting trial
they have pleaded not guilty it's the
kind of local reporting that is so
critical and it's the kind of local
reporting that's suffering given the
landscape and journalism these days you
know so it's one of the things that
ProPublica was hoping to address with
the local reporting network who in some
small way make up for that and and to
help bolster this kind of critical
reporting in local newsrooms it was a
different kind of betrayal by police
that an investigative reporter
discovered in Alaska convicted felons
who were able to get jobs as police
officers in some of the state's remote
villages places where until recently few
reporters ever showed up my name is Kyle
Hopkins I'm a reporter and editor for
the Anchorage Daily News in Anchorage
Alaska a lot of the stories that we want
to cover and a lot of the best stories
are in these are plum villages that are
hard hard for us to get to there are all
these small communities with all these
small governments and they work you know
in the shadows they just do thank you
what they like because there's there's
no one paying attention because their
communities just are not large enough to
support on the local journalism I found
that again and again you would see
someone who had been accused of domestic
violence or you know rape or homicide
and you would also find that that person
had at what point and sometimes still
was through me as the village police
officer as Hopkins discovered when he
traveled to this village above the
Arctic Circle the village of Selawik
population 850 on November night three
years ago someone gave up
the 16 year old Lois Cleveland and then
raped her she died that night and while
the medical examiner called it
undetermined reasons you know they when
when Alaska State Troopers investigated
they found that she had handcuff marks
on her wrists and the state police soon
determined that the village police
officer who reported the crime
Brent Norton was in fact the one who
committed the crime in an interview
recorded by state police
Norton admitted he had given her liquor
and had sex with her while she was
unconscious did he do anything to her
while she was passed out
yeah it was not his first crime Hopkins
discovered you know a simple background
check show that he already had been
convicted of bootlegging and he was on
probation for giving alcohol to another
underage girl so you know was had been
you know gone through the criminal
justice system was accused of and found
to be guilty of a crime and was still on
the job the young victims mother was
distraught and then Hopkins set out in
the state capital to ask the officials
in charge if there were other police
officers like Norton convicted of
serious crimes but still on the job and
the response from Sprague lips were a
body you know and their job is to keep
track of the stuff was you'll we have no
idea they just they didn't know they
said no one knew that led to a
full-fledged effort by Hopkins and the
Anchorage Daily News to find out why
felt like it's the story that I had been
missing had been right for my face for
years and we got them finally just
finally into dress this and he has he is
the recipient this year of a grant from
the nonprofit
pro-public to continue his reporting as
a kind of one-man wrecking ball against
apathy and corruption I appreciate you
putting a spotlight on local reporting
it's a lonely job nobody wants it out
here so in a follow-up report Kyle
Hopkins tells us he found that one in
three Alaska communities have no police
at all and that incredibly there are
still sex offenders serving as police
officers next the reporter who put his
life on the line to go undercover in a
Louisiana prison when we return
back now with our special edition
highlighting some of the great local
investigative reporting that often does
not get the attention it deserves
like the reporter from Mother Jones who
went undercover in a potentially very
dangerous place inside a private
for-profit prison a place that's worked
hard to keep journalists and the public
from knowing what is going on behind its
walls the assignment was to get hired as
a guard inside this privately run prison
known as the wind Correctional Center in
Winfield Louisiana soon I'm gonna be in
there for eight hours a day and then
soon after that I'm gonna be in there
for twelve hours a day
this prison is crazy
beyond anything I ever imagined 1,500
inmates overseen by guards making $9 an
hour mother jones reporter Shane Bauer
was quickly hired I'm one of my first
day of training he's the head of
training said to us that at CCA we'll
hire anybody she said you know people
people say that we're scraping the
bottom of the barrel but we're not but
if you have a driver's license and are
breathing and are willing to work than
were willing to hire you inside a place
of chaos and violence all captured on
video by Bauer with a camera hidden in
his watch that he smuggled inside I was
surprised with how kind of bare-bones
the operation was you know there was
very little staff there were you know
maybe 25 guards for 1,500 prisoners
which kind of leads the prison to be
more violence than other prisons in the
state there was an escape while I was
there in the middle of the day and Bauer
says the prison company cut corners on
medical care for the prisoners by
actually my first day in the president
met a man who prisoner who had lost his
legs and fingers to gangrene Bauer says
the company is slow to send anyone to an
outside hospital because it has to pay
the bill we're not acting like it
[Music]
that's how we've been treated what kind
of pictures you get there get my picture
what you took here don't belong be yours
cover was finally blown when a
photographer for Mother Jones James West
was spotted outside the prison taking
exterior shots and sheriff's department
deputies demanded to see what was on his
camera all right you can't see my camera
I'll tell you why I think the best I do
is to see this camera no look at me if
you don't want to give it to me I will
take it we found out later that someone
at the Sheriff's Department had searched
James's video without a warrant and on
that video was an interview that he had
done with me that day I'm talking about
working in the prison so they were able
to kind of connect that that I was you
know journalists Bauer quickly moved out
calling in his resignation to the prison
company I'm actually calling because I
decided to resign Bauer's stories and
Mother Jones and a subsequent book got
the attention of the US Department of
Justice and shortly afterwards the Obama
administration announced that they were
going to stop using private prisons on
the federal level this of course is
reversed as soon as Donald Trump became
president so now it's kind of you know
it's back to where it was before all the
more reason that Bauer's undercover
reporting is now so important yeah I
mean we have a rich tradition of
undercover journalism in this country
and it's only in the last couple decades
that we haven't seen it as much and I
think that we have a right to see you
know when companies are serving as
public institutions what they're doing
and if they're not going to allow us
access then we have to figure out how to
get it in a statement the company that
ran the prison later called Shane Bowers
conduct reckless but did not address in
any way the appalling conditions Bauer
discovered and documented inside the
prison next a shout out for the
reporters in Philadelphia who carried
out their own kind of
undercover assignment that had huge
impact on the lives and health of
schoolchildren in their city it was news
that shocked the city dangerous levels
of mold lead asbestos inside more than a
dozen Philadelphia schools all the
result of the two year-long project
called toxic city six schools by the
Philadelphia Inquirer and two
enterprising reporters I'm Wendy
Ruderman on the reporter for the
Philadelphia Inquirer and I'm Barbara
Laker I'm a reporter also for the
Philadelphia Inquirer after the scandal
of dangerous lead levels in the drinking
water in Flint Michigan
the two reporters wanted to know what
the story was in Philadelphia we wanted
to take a look at Philadelphia's numbers
and see if children in Philadelphia were
being exposed to lead and we learned
that kids in Philadelphia were actually
exposed to lead and had led poisoning at
far higher rates than in flesh Flint
Michigan and so they looked first at
homes and landlords then playgrounds and
finally school we were actually really
shocked how bad the conditions were in
the schools but it took months of work
to prove it and a lot of stealth finding
teachers to conduct tests inside the
school teachers were very reluctant they
were afraid of retribution from the
school district but ultimately we did
get 26 teacher to help us do the testing
and 19 of the most rundown schools the
reporters could not go into schools
themselves to avoid being accused of
trespassing and it was all very
hush-hush as the equipment and test
results were passed back and forth it
was almost like it was like a drug deal
or something it was kind of funny and
crazy but they would hand us these
little vials filled with dose wipes and
then we would take them over to the lab
the results made headlines and teachers
at a Philadelphia K through 8 school
have just about had and students at one
of the schools even wrote letters to
local officials we need funding for a
better school it's like the school is
falling apart
dear state senator Vincent use every day
I go to school I feel like I'm in a
prison or a junkyard
school can fire it down any time so our
doors are broken broken computers and
leaking heaters we had one little boy
Dean Fagin he was a first grader in a
school and he was sitting at his desk
trying to learn and there was a ton of
lead paint on the ceiling above his desk
and it fell on his desk and on the floor
beside his desk and he was scared that
he'd get in trouble having a messy desk
and he thought he'd also the teacher
would be mad at him if he got up to put
it in the trashcan so we ate the lead
paint chips on his desk and he ended up
having a lead level of like 46 which is
I mean off-the-charts high he was
hospitalized for three days and nights
and he was left the reporters say with
serious learning disabilities this
afternoon the mayor and other city
leaders visited a middle school the
story finally got the attention of
school officials who at first had been
highly critical of the reporter's
efforts the testing methodology that was
employed by the reporters we have
already come out and been very clear
that we don't agree with that but under
public pressure the schools launched a
massive 15 million dollar cleanup
campaign at the seven schools named by
the Philadelphia Inquirer as having the
worst conditions but that sort of raises
questions about all the schools that we
didn't get into and we couldn't get
teachers to test or we just you know
it's just it's just so vast it was a big
commitment from our newsroom and it
involved pretty much the whole staff and
yes my myself and Barbara and Dylan
Purcell who helped us do a lot of the
data analysis of maintenance Long's
ultimately our job is to expose
something that's wrong and shed light on
it and then empower people with
knowledge and then on top of that
empower the community to actually pick
up the ball and have conversations that
make change and that's what's happening
here in Philly coming up next in our
special edition of shout out for someone
who never had a byline in his newspaper
but whose writing has made a very big
difference
finally tonight a shout-out for someone
who works at the New York Times but
doesn't get a byline even so it was what
he wrote in response to president
Trump's attacks on the New York Times
that made a lot of news my name is David
McLeod I am the deputy general counsel
at the New York Times Company and my
primary responsibility is anything that
comes out of the newsroom that presents
a legal problem
David McCoy has never won a Pulitzer
Prize or even had a New York Times
byline but I told him that in newsrooms
around the country
he is seen as a hero in an era of
journalism under attack I'm not sure I'm
gonna buy into the hero label but
certainly I've had a platform to stand
up for journalism and I'm proud to do
that it has put him head-to-head with
Donald Trump the New York Times is
totally dishonest totally dishonest I
think the main thing that concerns me
has been the attempt by the President
and others to delegitimize the press it
really is an invitation to distrust to
not believe you are fake news you are
the enemy of the people you look at the
network so you look at the news you look
at the newscast I call it fake news I
draw a line between that and criticism
with the press press should be
criticized any institution should but
this idea of just to dismiss it as fake
news enemy the people I think has been
deadly do you think Donald Trump
believes that I think he knows that it
plays well to a political base I don't
know whether he really thinks that is a
true fact and the New York Times is
failing if I weren't here I believe the
New York Times probably wouldn't even
exist when he continues to refer to the
time there's the failing New York Times
what's the reaction inside this building
it's a little amusing because as you
know he also talks about how he saved
the New York Times because subscriptions
went through the roof when he was
elected and that's really closer to the
truth in his new book truth in our times
McCrory calls perhaps his finest hour as
he came to the defense of a New York
Times report about two women who claimed
Trump had physically groped them
he was like an octopus it was like he
had six arms he was all over the place
Trump than a candidate annually
denied the allegation now we address the
slander and libel that was just last
night thrown at me by the Clinton
machine and the New York Times and other
media outlets as part of a concerted
coordinated and vicious attack and
overnight Trump's lawyer demanded The
Times retract its story and issue an
apology saying quote failure to do so
will leave my client with no option but
to pursue all available actions and
remedies I felt that we needed to have a
strong response the response was this
letter from the craw no retraction
essentially see you in court we did what
the law allows we publish newsworthy
information about a subject of deep
public concern if mr. Trump disagrees if
he believes that American citizens had
no right to hear what these women had to
say and the law of this country forces
us and those who would dare to criticize
him to stand silent or be punished we
welcome the opportunity to have a court
set him straight the letter went viral
in the end I think the people two times
were very happy that I'd done it this
way
and I'm fortunate to work in a company
that was going to stand behind me for a
response is strong that's our program
for tonight thanks for joining us we'll
see you back here next week
goodnight